taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
how you taste buddies it's the taste
buds podcast i
am joe i am salvatore today's
battle peanut butter and jelly
versus grilled cheese holy cow this is
one of the ones that i think
are two indestructible forces going up
against each other
i honestly don't know who is the front
runner coming into this do you
uh no i i i'm very curious to see how
this is gonna go because
um hold on first of all it's out
it's dropped it it's out all right
dropped it on twitter
people are starting to vote
these are two childhood classics these
are two
these are two sandwiches this is why we
do this podcast
yeah these are two sandwiches that like
this is like
on a random tuesday you go
to the supermarket and go i want to eat
this for dinner tonight
yeah i'm going to have three grilled
cheese sandwiches for dinner
i've had grilled cheese and peanut
butter and jelly for breakfast i've had
them for lunch
i've had them for dinner i've had it for
snacks exactly i love them yeah i love
both of them
i'm gonna pick a side but i love both
and i contest that most people
do love both they're they're they were
favorites in childhood their favorites
today
they are i mean people live and die on a
peanut butter and jelly hill or grilled
cheese hill
yes they will die on the sword on that
hill and
and i have one of these on the joey
rose's menu and it's not the one i'm
arguing for
oh a little hinsky yeah but uh
i will tell you i believe wholeheartedly
in the one i'm arguing for
as do i and i will eventually bring this
to the menu but right now
i also believe in the one i'm arguing
against
but damn it i mean right there it looks
so good so does yours
oh that looks good i know that just a
soft
all right here's what we're doing guess
right now
i am going peanut butter and jelly baby
yes it's peanut butter jelly time yeah
i'm going grilled cheese
uh do you want to kick things off sure
go ahead
instead of trashing the grilled cheese
which i think it's a great sandwich
i almost can't trash it i can tell you
why i like peanut butter and jelly more
i'm going to start off with the
positives of peanut butter and jelly
yeah because and before you even do that
i was going to ask you because this this
this one was your idea yeah what made
you even think of this
because these are the only two
sandwiches that i can think of that can
go up against each other
i thought at first the first thing that
came to me was who's fighting peanut
butter and jelly because to me
that's my favorite sandwich of all time
i love
i told you i love three things i love
cereal peanut butter jelly and raviol
i'm a simple man i am a simple man and
if i could
if health was no consequence i would eat
cereal in the morning
peanut butter and jelly lunch ravioli or
some type of thing like that
at dinner meatless day yeah
pizza you throw in there those are the
four things i would eat really until i
croak
wow yeah okay this is something serious
when i was younger i was a picky eater
and i really gave my mom a hard time
and the only thing besides peanut butter
and jelly that i would eat believe it or
not was like
ham and cheese or like bologna and
cheese or just like
just ham just blowing you just pivot for
a second yes
baloney white american yellow mustard
white bread
i'm there all day as a kid you grew up
on that stuff
that's another one i'll do it straight
up oh also do that same exact sandwich
with instead of mustard mayo and tomato
all day yeah i'll do that for dinner but
i will tell you if i had to break it
down
i would say 70 30. but i only i only ate
two sandwiches
from grades k through eight i'm not even
i get i'll get my mom on the horn right
now
we had a i mean it was a thing i had to
break this woman because she's like you
can't have this every day and i was like
oh no and i went on just a hunger strike
and i would come home i would come home
every day with my brown bag with the
exact same
meal if it wasn't one of those things i
was like i refuse
and i might have even i might have even
gotten in trouble i might have even
taken
like i would slap on the ass something i
don't remember what i was gonna say i
would like to smack
you across the room i mean under the
audacity yeah
no but i would do and and i broke the
woman i broke her down you broke her
and then my mom gave me peanut butter
and jelly every day for like i'm not
kidding you
for nine years okay i i just you know i
have
an affinity to this sandwich i've never
heard someone
except unless you have a peanut allergy
i i and you are
you're adverse you're peanut adverse
i've never heard someone not say
that this is on the level of pizza for
them peanut butter and jelly is comfort
it's sweet it's salty it's good any time
it's good on toast
now before we get too heavy into the
debate let's do a little history
okay i want to see when did when did the
p it says right here the pb and j became
popular with children
with the advent of sliced bread in the
1920s
now hold on a second this is what bugs
me about some of these facts we get
this is saying sliced bread was invented
in the 1920s
we've had other debates today that
claimed sandwiches existed before that
right sandwiches no
soups sliced bread soup salad
no no wait wait 1928 there we go okay
i'll show you another thing
just sliced bread came out in 1928 rats
been around 66 million years yeah
uh okay peanut butter first peanut
butter 1901 the first peanut butter and
jelly sandwich recipe appeared in the
boston cooking school magazine of
culinary stuff
pbj and domestic economics written by
julia davis
well they didn't have sliced bread what
the hell were they putting it on uh
since world war ii both peanut butter
and jelly have been found on u.s
soldiers military's rations list
that's not a if that's not a vote for
pbj i don't know what is
okay give us a little grilled cheese
history pimp
in france the croquet yeah monsoor
toasted bread cheese and ham oh you're
talking my language was first on menus
in 1910
so kind of same thing grilled cheese
sandwiches became part of everyday menu
in the united states in the early 1900s
people have seen the first reference to
a melted cheese sandwich as early as
1902
and sarah tyson warriors misses
something
or other the cheese dream an open-faced
grilled cheese sandwich
i never heard of that popular in 19 in
the u.s during the great depression
okay so we're we're we're pretty neck
and neck here
with history grilled cheese is is
earlier but what i still can't wrap my
head around here is that
they're claiming these sandwiches popped
up before the 20s and they're saying
they didn't have sliced
bread before the 20s what the hell were
they making great not even get caught up
there all right
fine now i okay now here we go
you explain why you picked it you kind
of did the history you kind of cut me
off but it's okay
oh wait i cut you off well i was kind of
i was in the middle of it i was saying
let's do a little history
because because a podcast needs order i
agree with you a podcast needs order
and no offense you're all over the place
sometimes
and you need to be reeled in oh yeah
yeah that's just me yeah
you got it sure i i
i we said we thought of peanut butter
and jelly this is how we think of the
episodes right like if it's in regular
conversation we thought of peanut butter
and jelly
and i said well who the hell can beat a
peanut butter and jelly
and we kept it there and on our shared
notes on our phone
right until one day we said what about
the grilled cheese
that's an iconic sandwich that people
love and everybody has their own little
like oh
you haven't had my grilled cheese did
you say it or did i add grilled cheese
i don't remember but i i agree it's a
worthy adversary because grilled cheese
is unbelievable right
so here's the thing okay peanut butter
and jelly i was touching on this
um i could have it truly for breakfast
lunch dinner or a snack
i love that i get both sweet and salty
savory and salty out of it
i love it as a triple sec free and sweet
you mean sorry savory and sweet
i love it as a triple decker i love my
favorite sandwich in the world
is peanut butter and jelly on toast now
you can't once you
take the heat and the toast out of the
grilled cheese
that becomes white bread with two slices
of cheese so you can't even
my point peanut butter jelly is good
cold or toasted whereas grilled cheese
is just a toasted sandwich
and when you toast peanut butter and
jelly it becomes a different experience
because the peanut butter a melty peanut
butter that starts to get the swirl of
jelly in it
is just heavenly and and also i also
enjoy
jam and i and i feel that jam and jelly
are synonymous but jam is
i like this spreadability of jam over
jelly jelly that feels a little
so good
good i'm sorry is everything okay i'm
listening to you go ahead
i'm listening i'll take what do you want
me to do cartwheels around the room
no but you you you you you you had
umbridge with something i was thinking
huh you took out no i was i was gonna
say something and then you were still
still talking so i stopped talking
well he just brought up an uncrusted or
is it crustable or an uncrustable what's
it called big fan
a big fan like i'm a huge fan of
uncrustable oh it's uncrustable there's
no crust
yeah yeah so look i like it on i love
your standard
here's what i'm saying the peanut butter
and jelly can be made a
thousand ways to sundae i think that
even in the
simplest iteration white bread let's
call it
skippy peanut butter welch's grape jelly
or jam
right there you almost can't even beat a
variation of it
although the variations are amazing if
you're putting it on just
fresh baked bread or a bagel or
anything and if you're getting these
gourmet peanut butters shout out
saratoga peanut butter god bless them we
love
them we're gonna do they're gonna do a
thing with our saratoga
and you know what's so funny this is the
food podcast and we haven't mentioned
tara toga yet
shout out saratoga peanut butter guy
it's just a place that i found
a peanut butter i found at a christmas
market that i've been eating ever since
and i've turned on 200 people the
flavors are unbelievable
it's low in carbs and sugar they're not
a sponsor all right
i'm sorry i have to i have to shout them
out
well they're not a sponsor but now we're
gonna we're gonna
join sarah toga peanut butter and make a
flavor
especially for us and a portion will go
to charity
uh just what the hell are you talking
about
i'm talking about what i just said i
know it sounds crazy we are going to do
this
well hey babe but you know what it
really is no pressure
how about we talk about our podcast i
don't know but
you're talking about what hay babe is
doing this is a satellite no no no
i'm talking about saratoga it's a
satellite of peanut butter peanut butter
conversation i'd say i take a straight
skippy but peanut butter and jelly
it's it's unbelievable i don't
understand anything you just said
you mentioned charity at some point a
christmas market
who is doing what is going on right now
i'm sorry
sidebar saratoga peanut butter is a
small company run by a lovely woman
that i found at a christmas market years
ago better
become a a customer and you're gonna
pass it along to people and i talked
about it
when they got wind of it okay and now
we're gonna collaborate who's we
uh well it's hey babe but honestly no
presh really it could be good
yeah we should do a no press situation
where we do a taste buds and a hey babe
flavor instead of a crown
you know i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i
hope that i don't mean for keeping you
in to crash the party here so sorry see
this is taste buds
saratoga belongs here more than anything
you have talked for so long at this
point
my points you don't just let me go i
thought this was going to be a friendly
one
it's i'm getting it why would it be i'm
getting friendly
butter and the gel if you don't get when
i when i say a gc if you don't get what
i'm talking about and you can beep this
you're a dumb [ __ ] okay first of all
okay
in fact you could beep this you're a
dumb what
so wow that's first off yeah now i'll
tell you this right now
pb and j there's one iteration and it is
one of my favorite sandwiches of all
time one of my favorites
hold on hold on hold on
talking to the mic yeah talking to the
mic
that's what it's there no i was shouting
so i didn't want to shot into the mic
the uh okay
uh pb and j white bread
peanut butter grape jelly potato chips
on it or on the side
that's it that's it i don't want to see
strawberry jelly on it
i don't want to see i'm talking now
i'm talking now it's my turn i have the
floor i don't want to see a peach jelly
on it
i don't want to see a jam i don't want
to see a boysenberry
preserve i want to see grape jelly
i'm talking smucker's style whatever you
like that's the versatility of the pb
i'm talking peanut butter and i'm
talking of a white bread in its base
whether it's a roll
or a white bread in in its true form
whatever but that's it for me
that's how i like it that's how i want
it however
a grilled cheese i mean let's get it
started
here american white or yellow black eyed
peas get it started go ahead american
white or yellow
provolone swiss cheddar
monster can forget about it
forget about it well yeah that's how it
works that's how grilled cheese works
okay you get the butter do you want
salted butter
do you want regular butter who knows are
you putting bacon
on it are you putting ham on it are you
putting tomato
on it are you putting another turkey on
no no no joe
joe joe yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah right now
it's peanut butter and jelly versus
grilled cheese the original cheese
you put ham on it oh get the when it was
invented with ham on it oh
it was invented don't go back to 1910
and go
but the original we're talking about a
grilled chicken
reason we bring the history what do you
think grilled cheese you think cheese
melted on two slices of bread griddled
okay fine you turn it on you go you
could put ham and turkey on it now you
got a ham and turkey and cheese
so let me get this straight you can
switch up jellies and jams and i can't
switch up what i put on my grilled
cheese no you could switch up to cheese
but you can't add turkey and ham
grilled ham and cheese stupid bastard go
to the invention of the grilled cheese
go to the invention of the grilled
cheese go back to the invention you know
toasted bread cheese and ham that's how
it was invented
by monsieur croquet in 1910 you dick
yeah that's how it was invented you you
what are you doing
what are you doing you're red they're
the
[Laughter]
the girl she says good enough to argue
on its own while you're bringing ham and
turkey into this you're ruining your
whole life i'm just talking about
me just the way you said you got this
cheese you got that cheese
so can i put pickles can i put pickles
on it
[ __ ] you can i put pickles on no on the
side
a nice pickle you're a stupid dumb
[ __ ]
you stupid dumb ass hole you can you can
you make no
sense it's humidity you
you you name different cheeses then you
tell me all right
jelly you need peanut butter and jelly i
said the word
jelly jelly means whatever jelly all
right you want to
put on it i need different cheese you
name different jellies
turkey 1910 monster okay
i will tell you this i will i will be
honest
[Music]
you gotta stay on the mic do you
understand
how the microphones work do you
understand
you've got your grilled cheese you know
what i love about it
turkey no it's a grilled cheese melt
getting cheese all right already all
right
listen to me listen to me you could ch
i'll stick with the change-up of the
cheeses okay 2002
survey showed the average american well
you're gonna do 100 of these peanut
butter and jelly sandwich before
graduating
from high school and if you think that's
a lot the average kid is 250
100 jellies before high school do you
think you want me to
argue the grilled cheese or not do you
want me to argue with you i would love
it i'll take that thank you for showing
up i'll take the ham off the table
even though every other argument you
make he he brings
more inclination you know what a grilled
cheese is also it's probably also called
a crepe you dope
i got several texts about crepes several
sleep arguments whatever your crepe
arguments
was one of the low points oh [ __ ] you
you according to a recent study
conducted by yougov.com grilled cheese
is the most popular sandwich in the
country country
i'm saying what's better though now
what's most popular from a
representative sample of
1 223 people staple comfort food won the
heart to 79
of people sorry look we're gonna go
right actually from 2019
we're gonna go right no [ __ ] it gives me
the buddy you know we're gonna go right
to cheese
let me fix it let me finish let me say
it can i say it or do you want to scream
and dance some more tell me how you want
to add ham and turkey
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god some balls oh my god i only
brought it out because
it was invented you take a grilled
cheese
you take a grilled cheese on sourdough
okay
it is it is immaculate you take a
grilled cheese on white bread
it is immaculate okay the butter
soaking into the bread the crispiness
okay
it is so good it is so good that that
style of bread is brought into other
sandwiches
that technique is brought into other
sandwiches now i won't argue those
sandwiches
but that style of almost a french toast
surrounding the cheese is used in other
sandwiches
you can't say that about peanut butter
and jelly the best thing you can say
about peanut butter
and jelly is they also put it on
crackers that's it
you could take a long walk right now
okay just like you could change
any bread for the grilled cheese you
could put peanut butter and jelly on any
bread my point is you ever have a
you ever had you've heard of peanut
butter jelly on pumpernickel you'll blow
your brains out
you'll blow your brains out anything you
ever have a peanut butter jelly on a on
a coarse
uh a seeded rye you you don't like it
yes
you don't like it i love rye you're nuts
okay here's the thing about
hey sal what are you doing trying to
quit
trying to quit ziggy's i'm trying to
wean myself off i wish it was a nicotine
alternative joe i
got news for you you know lucy not a
person
a nicotine alternative lozenges and gum
that you can chew to get you off of that
nasty habit
what tell me more well i'll tell you
something
these products were invented by cal
tech scientist california technician
scientist yes and actual
ex-smokers yeah and these were made for
who
people people not patients not patients
i i i this were this close quite frankly
i've got no patience for people
that's exactly right which is why i like
this product
yeah so so it's convenient it's discreet
it's delivered right to your door that's
another thing i like because what just
happened
was you're a smoker okay and i'm pushing
you
we're gonna try lucy and i'm gonna have
you try lucy and we're gonna see
how this fares for you but you just told
me
oh my god i'm you just said this you
said i'm out of smokes that's right
do you mind if we take a ride to the
store just so you can buy smokes right
and like most cigarette smokers i don't
like to move at all that's right so
we called the friend terry we called a
friend who we will be seeing
later and said can you just bring
cigarettes to me yeah but with money
that's not happening that's not
absolutely deliberate
he's your friend that's going to deliver
it without you don't get to bring a
third party into this
no throw it's 20 21 throw the vape away
throw away your cigarettes you stink
it's you smoke you choke you cough it's
just gross man
just pop a stick of gum in your mouth
this is the real deal and
in the past uh now i'm not a heavy heavy
smoker but in the past i have tried to
wean off completely with
the use of like a pharmacy brand
nicotine gum or whatever i hadn't had
much luck uh and i will say this lucy is
the real deal it's a subscription
that comes as we said directly to your
door and look
here's the thing you got nothing to lose
here's why
you go to lucy.co lucy.co
you use the promo code tastebuds you're
going to get 20 off all products
including gums
or lozenges guys twenty percent gals
you know what twenty percent fifty
percent off
that's not true sixty you can't back
that up
it's only gonna be 20 i'm sorry
twenty percent that's it i mean
do you want ninety nine because i don't
understand how marketing works
you're not supposed to retract the
discount
how about this disc two hundred percent
on order lucy i'll send it to you with
10 bucks i'll tell you what
20 off the product a product that's
going to give you
60 off the shortcomings of smoking
how about that look you know what's
coming up you are our listeners
and you get the special code uh lucy dot
co use the promo code taste budget you
get 20
off that's lucy.co.com uh promo code
tastebuds to check
out the product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco and nicotine is an
addictive chemical yes
we need to say that yeah we have to give
that a disclaimer but it doesn't mean
that this is not a healthier alternative
to for you than smoking so
give it a shot they've got a lot of
great flavors that's it
we hope you enjoy it we hope it helps
you out we believe it will
it's 20 i couldn't do anything i tried
always has to get the last word
always has to get the last word 20 sally
babe
hey this is it oh we got
this is how how nice this is joey roses
aka joe derosa's sandwich shop has
brought a platter of sandwiches yes
a platter of sandwiches for us to eat
and taste it now
because of the nature of quarantine i
have not been down to the shop this is
going to be my first
bite this is it this is your first one
now and i've plugged the sandwich pop up
many times we're at the stand in nyc in
union square
uh every week always follow the
instagram joey rose's hard eight
i'm glad that dory covert two you bit it
and then put it right down on top of
a plate of clean sandwiches
jesus christ we're at the stand in union
square every week
where's this bread from we make it what
we make it we make it in our hotel we
make it in house
quality stuff eight sandwiches for eight
bucks a piece you can't beat it
these are cheaper than going to subway
and it's ten times the quality
so i mean come on down enjoy us
i'm not kidding around this is dull
absolutely delicious like
home run quality ingredients they fill
you better
they taste better they are better joey
roses we do quality
better that's right sandwiches elevated
a brand based around phallus talk
put it in your mouth hey buddy what do
you say
what do you say sal what are you shut up
i'm glad we got together tonight to zoom
each other because we couldn't get
together in person i just wish i could
hear you a little better
my on-board uh speakers are terrible
you're on what are you doing using
onboard
come on you know you don't got 87 pairs
of headphones around the house
no i don't have any i'm actually looking
for any can you recommend any
sal i think i can
you had them in your right hand raycon
just by chance wow
these are raycon wireless earbuds these
were sent to me by
raycon the company which is ray j the uh
musicians
company uh and i gotta tell you these
are amazing
these are an amazing affordable way to
listen to whatever it is you want to
listen to whether you're catching up on
podcasts maybe taste buds
uh maybe you're binging an audiobook
which i often do
maybe you're powering through your
workout which i never do so
i don't know but the
the raycons are great they make all the
difference there's no dangling wires
in fact the only reason i'm not using
them right now is because when i record
from home
the microphone i used requires hardwired
earbuds which
don't worry about that i need to know
one thing and one thing only do they
break the bank
no no and that's what that's the best
part and honestly
honestly it's right it's they're kind of
given the
the earbud game the high quality earbud
game i should say
a run for its money because they've made
these things incredibly
affordable they're built to perform
anywhere anytime
uh they've got water and sweat resistant
construction
uh and your bluetooth pairs quickly and
seamlessly and that is for real man like
i've been using these this week as soon
as i hooked it up
my iphone recognized it right away the
way it does with the apple brand ones
which are
significantly more expensive uh you've
got battery life
for about six hours of play time so
oh oh also the best part the best part
the best part
and this is kind of what i've been
alluding to the great sound
that they are offering they're making it
accessible to everyone because they're
starting
at half the price of other premium
audio brands so do you want to get
yourself a pair
i do and i think right now raycon is
offering 15 off
all their products for our listeners and
here's
all you got to do is you go to buy recon
dot com
slash taste buds and that's it you'll
get 50 off your entire raipon order
uh you feel free to grab a pair and a
spare they're telling us
it's fifteen percent off at buy recon
dot com slash taste buds
by raycon dot com slash taste buds and
before we sign off i just wanna go
uh back to one thing you said the easy
connectivity with bluetooth
because i tell you that's one of my main
things
bluetooth never connects when it's
supposed to and i was considering
writing bluetooth
a stern letter
[Laughter]
but now with raycons if it's that easy
maybe it'll spare me having to deal with
the corporate bigwigs at bluetooth well
and i have tried and this is
this is for real like i have tried to
use other non-apple brand earbuds
or airpods or whatever you want to call
them with my iphone and it never
works because the phone won't connect
with it properly it doesn't recognize
whatever
these raycons are the first type
ever that we're not only affordable but
seamlessly connected that that's the
real deal like
yeah i'm sold i'm getting a pair and if
you out there you're listening
and you're having the same issues we're
talking to you you might as well just
get 15 off go to buyraikon.com
taste buds so let's take a break and
talk about one of our new sponsors
keeps kids they're helping men
uh that are having a certain problem
which i a lot of my friends are having
this now did you know that two out of
three men will experience some form of
hair loss by the time they're 35
i wouldn't have believed that if you had
told me that when i was 30 and now that
i'm 40
for me uh yeah i can tell you that
that's true
in dog years you're like thousands of
years old i think
yeah yeah but i mean it's i have i have
quite a few friends who are between the
ages of 35
and let's say 44 uh who are experiencing
hair loss
and are trying to figure out ways to
not necessarily reverse it but stop it
in its tracks
and and does that keep keeps can stop it
from falling out
and prevent it you're right more than 50
million men in the u.s suffer from
male pattern boldness now i am not one
of those i was lucky but my legs are
completely bald
which is odd and that's true pizza is
not going to help with that keeps is up
top here
it helps you keep right here that's
basically it right i mean i mean
i have noticed waking up in the mornings
now maybe a couple extra strands on my
pillow
i don't know if that's an indicator of
bad times ahead
not that going bald is bad but if your
preference is not to go bald
it's bad and that's the people who are
going to want to be interested in keeps
and if you're ready
to take action and prevent hair loss go
to k-e-e-p-s
dot com keeps.com taste buds to receive
your first month of treatment
for free some sometimes with these deals
you get percentages off this is the
first month free
okay that's dot com slash taste buds
to get your first month free joe what is
it it's keeps
that's the product k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash taste buds
and they're gonna offer you convenient
virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months so you
don't have to leave home
sounds pretty good to me low cost
treatments start at just ten dollars per
month
again sounds pretty good to me keith
keeps also
offers generic versions which will save
you some cash sounds good to me a third
time
discreet packaging proven results keeps
us more than
keeps us more five-star reviews than any
of its competitors prevention
is key and treatment can take four to
six
months to keep that hair in so act fast
again
k e e p s dot com slash taste buds
uh grilled cheese okay it's good but
it's the same
taste right i'm biting into it it's
great honestly by the end of the grilled
cheese honestly
i don't want to think about peanut
butter and jelly is a plethora of tastes
[Music]
grilled cheese and mustard it's all
about taste buds
i'll dip the grilled cheese in my mouth
up the taste buds
my senses come alive
so you're bringing in a component of my
sandwich
over to the grilled cheese because i
hate fig jam on peanut butter but i'll
dip some i'll dip a grilled cheese fake
jam fit into this argument
because it's a great thing to dip your
grilled cheese into i'm talking about
grilled cheese
it gives it a great flavor you get a
grayer
grilled cheese putting fig into it
stop playing speak into it i am i'm
saying you can dip it into things and
it's great
i can dip my balls into fig sauce and
it'll be great
don't tell me what you could dip it into
tell me about this all right hold on
hold on let's regroup here
i already described why the sandwich is
good
i already described it my my versatility
is a big argument on this podcast and
you know that it is
i think jelly is more versatile than
grilled cheese you can't
it's all you're doing right if i tell
you that i think grilled cheese
with a fig jam is delicious with a
certain type of cheese or grilled
cheese stop with the fish no stop stop
stop cheese on bread melted joe with
butter
stop with the jam what no don't take
fake from me that's like saying put it
to yourself
you know what i'll do i'll make a peanut
butter jelly i'll put a little parmesan
you you said hold on a second that's
like saying oh you can't argue the
cheeseburger because you can't you can't
say that ketchup is a nice addition to
it
you can't do that you can't do that you
can't do that and you know it peanut
butter and jelly
sandwiches may be a staple of childhood
but its popularity is so endless
that it's estimated that the average
american will consume almost
3 000 of them during the course of their
lifetime okay
356 days in a year that's quick math
you're having a peanut butter and jelly
almost every day for 10 years
that's the average person okay what's
that got to do with what you got peanut
butter you got smooth and creamy you got
chunky you got honey roasted yeah okay
saratoga peanut butter keep naming
peanut butter and jelly peanut butter
strawberry jelly serves yeah we get it
right you gotta get it you can switch up
peanut butter and the jelly are together
on bread what are you doing with it
they even sell peanut butter and jelly
in a jar together already
okay dude peanut butter and jelly is a
brick [ __ ] house
what are you doing with it once it's in
the sandwich
that's what i'm showing it's swallowing
i'm doing a little skit i love it
i love it i told you already i love it
but you can't tell me a grilled i love a
grilled cheese plain
out of the pan i love it when you cause
you could dip it in mustard i tasted it
i
even like this thing from the sweet and
the savory you're only getting savory
with grilled cheese
you it's delicious but listen
i can only eat so much cheese and so
much butter before i'm like
i've had enough sometimes when i have a
grilled cheese it's delicious but by the
time i'm at the last bite
i'm like that did its thing that was the
purpose of it i can't eat any more
grilled cheese let me tell you peanut
butter and jelly when i finish it i'm
like
do i make another peanut butter and
jelly okay okay
so what's that gotta do with anything
what do you mean what's life what's that
got to do with telling you that
what's like when i eat i don't like
telling you i can only eat so much prime
rib
i'm telling you i love them both i'm
telling you i love them both but i could
eat
three peanut butter sandwiches americans
eat approximately
2.2 billion grilled cheese sandwiches a
year
according to a market research study now
i will tell you this sal let's let's
let's let's let's shift the argument a
little bit
you know what exists for me but doesn't
exist for you
grilled cheese restaurants grilled
cheese restaurants you're wrong
and when you burn jelly restaurants and
when you walk in those restaurants
do you think that they are not having
hey here's one with a fig jam
here's one with a bacon on it here's one
with this here's one with that do you
think they are not celebrating the
versatility of grilled cheese
it's not called a grilled ham and cheese
it's called a grilled cheese with ham
but then i could say
peanut butter and jelly with honey pure
and jelly banana peanut butter and jelly
say it griddled
i'm all ears say it make the argument
i'm all yours i'm listening
i'm listening how much more olly
oxen-free how much melted cheese and
butter can you bite into let me tell you
something right now and this is all
let's talk about this right here
you're gonna you're gonna bring in
tomato soup
you mean the you mean the staple you
mean these
i can't i can't do it may god jesus lord
help me
please jesus i don't understand why you
guys because
you you you you it's impossible to break
rules because you don't abide by
them you will argue one thing and in the
next podcast in the next episode
you will argue the opposite of that
thing how am i arguing the opposite
what does tomato soup have to do with
the grilled cheese
cheese and a tomato soup is that that's
like that's a staple sandwich
meal peanut butter and jelly with potato
chips milk i'm not bringing all that
other stuff in here
it's grilled cheese versus peanut butter
and jelly not tomato soup not fig
jam okay so then what are we talking
about here because you're saying you
like
sandwiches
this is all you need to know this is all
you buddies you need to know okay
joey roses has a sandwich shop
he owns and runs and it's deeper let me
finish
is the propriety i'm having a stroke
it's the proprietor of a sandwich shop
it only has eight sandwiches
that's the whole concept it's eight
sandwiches they're not overwhelming you
they're eight amazing sandwiches done
right he owns a sandwich shop
peanut butter and jelly is one of his
eight sandwiches
grilled cheese is not you know what's
the menu you know why
do you know why peanut butter and jelly
because i will tell you exactly why my
friend
because we do cold sandwiches only i
have a menu coming out of eight hot
sandwiches
and you better bet your goddamn bottom
dollar
point that grilled cheese is on that and
you know what's on that grilled cheese
possibly a little bit of ham no problem
because you love
you can't stand behind the grilled
cheese and this is your form
because you don't have enough oh i don't
need to i don't need i don't need to put
the ham on that i'm putting it on it
because it's just
because i just know what i'm doing i
i'll do it i'll do it without the
without the ham any day of the week and
i'll stand by it all day long i'll stand
by it all day long but you keep bringing
tomato soup you put them in that kitchen
downstairs
so far three cheeses and and bread and
butter
i'm gonna make your sandwich it's gonna
knock your socks off i'm not saying that
a grilled cheese sandwich butter is the
best thing ever made in the world right
but i'm saying i eat one grilled cheese
and i'm like i it's a bit rich it's a
bit much
i i don't daydream of grilled cheese
every day
i gotta be in the mood for a grilled
cheese peanut butter and jelly
i'll have it every day all day every
meal it don't matter
every meal do you still hear me but i
can't i could eat it way more than
grilled cheese
joe we've been we've been talking for a
few minutes and you've brought tomato
soup fig spread
and ham and i don't understand a second
hold on a second hold on a second no
what i brought into it was i like that
the grilled cheese can be dipped into
many different dressings
and those dressings can each enhance the
flavor of the grilled cheese
i could i think peanut butter and jelly
into something you can't
but we argue versatility and you're
saying it's just
cheese on this and i'm saying no it's
not you
again i will make this point if you
argued the cheeseburger
you would not argue that it has to
always just be the base of
cheese beef and a roll you wouldn't
argue it like that
you would talk about what ketchup does
on a burger how great that is
some people like mayonnaise on their
burger some people like
barbecue those things are components of
a cheeseburger
that's how versatile the cheeseburgers
do you think these things are not
components of a grocery store
we'll go back to my argument of pancakes
and waffles if you tell me pick you up
if i if i give you a a a deli uh
piece of styrofoam with a sandwich and i
say have that it's a grilled cheese i
didn't finish it and you open it up
and it's tomato soup with a grilled
cheese
every diner menu under grilled cheese it
says
add bacon tomato turkey it gives you the
options
but for an extra price that is in
addition
to what the grilled cheese is and you're
arguing for a grilled cheese i'm just
saying i think a lot of people when
arguing the grilled cheese would take
into account
that there are things you can put on it
to dress it up a bit
okay that's all i'm saying i think
that's very fair okay that's all okay
that's
all but that's like saying i could
crunch up chips and put it on my
sandwich i wouldn't argue that i have
chips on my peanut butter and jelly
sandwich
that i serve in my sandwich shop pop-up
there are chips on this how delicious is
it
it's amazing but there are ruffled
potato chips on that sandwich for a
reason
because the peanut butter and jelly by
itself is too plain and too
straightforward
something needs to dress it up a little
well if it's on a restaurant menu i
agree but at home
no oh no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no because
you
dream about the pb and j you eat it
three times but you you can't have
someone come into a store you feel like
you can't just
you you feel you're just like you're
dreaming about it why not
it's gotta be good enough you just said
you can't just serve people peter
marjelli is too plain
maybe in a restaurant i'm not doing that
when i'm home you think i'm not doing
that when i'm home
you think i just wanna i no longer
do you think i just do you think my i'm
saying do you think it's on my menu just
because i go well it's a restaurant we
got a dress
no i go no i did this at home yeah
because that's what i do with my pb j at
home
you know what else i said when that
sandwich went on the menu and when
people said well what about strawberry
jam
what about this what about that i said
take a walk it is grape jelly
peanut butter but and that's it you
could choose any jelly you want just
like you could choose any cheese you
want
correct uh yeah no okay i agree but
you tell me you like a peanut butter
jelly with a strawberry jelly
i'm arguing the sandwich of peanut
butter any flavor and style
jelly any flavor and style on bread any
flavor and style
what's this say grilled cheese has a
short life span until it's just a
congealed mess
agreed let's talk about a grilled cheese
if you wait a few minutes
let's talk about that it becomes
something other world should ever take
do you ever take a pb and j to school
and the bread is purple by the time
you get to lunchtime i don't like it
it's disgusting now you're wrong
that's disgusting even when it is good i
regret it afterwards save the cheese for
the fries
pb and j is always good and satisfying
even if you go
to the lazy uncrustable route you can
toast the bread or not
pb and j for the win everything i said
okay okay great peanut butter
jelly one tweet agrees with you
congrats here we go i'm losing my voice
you're going batshit on this one i've
never seen you this worked up
grilled cheese is like an orgasm in your
mouth it's not the grilled cheese it's
that's not what's gonna be worked out
what's gonna be worked up
is the way that you dismantle the
the the fabric of the argument what is
the fabric of the argument
online cheese peanut butter and jelly
hold on a second you lead with i'm gonna
putting ham and
ham and turkey on it okay hold on a
second i didn't leave
all i said was you can add turkey you
can add bacon you can softer voices
and you started screaming at the top of
your lips you played the tape you were
screaming as well
no i was not screaming was i screaming
pimp i think i was
screaming over you no that is not true
also
you talked for 12 because you started
my gears about grinding yours you're
plugging
you're plugging hey babe adventures on
this thing what are you talking about
i'm telling you it's gonna become a
taste buds venture too
fine no reason but you start you went
off on some kind of dizzy rant about how
you're doing a cross promotion with a
peanut butter startup
that you found at a christmas fair i
don't know what the hell you're talking
about right now
some lady that's making it in her house
she's selling it out of jars
i don't know what you're talking about
not even arguing the grilled cheese
based on taste you keep going back to
croquet monsieur
listen listen all the only reason
i is that the real little dickie no
that's not little
the the only reason i brought
ham and turkey into the mix at the top
of this was because you were talking
about how great bacon is
in another episode okay
and we read the history of grilled
cheese and it said that the original
had ham in it and i thought well that's
very interesting because i often like to
add
a component to my grilled cheese a
tomato a turkey is it not enough
a bacon okay i just was trying to lead
strong with you can add these other
things
and that really oh boy did that set you
off
that that set you off that's good
because i
tell you oh i could eat an oreo hole or
split it in half and you go
you can't change the oreos by breaking
it in half
yes but then you're going i can add
turkey and ham and fig
like you know what i'm going to tell you
like even you want to do it
you got to stay consistent you want to
do a tally of us
of who's contradicted themselves not
saying i haven't contradicted exactly
okay okay well then i'm just saying i'm
just saying all right all right
all right maybe we're both flawed maybe
we both are a little hot onto the column
okay maybe we're both complicated people
okay all right
all right great where are we at
time-wise here pimp
all right great this one got hot
holy sh jesus all right let's go to the
let's go to the tweets
let's let's it also is a little it's a
lot tougher to make a grilled cheese on
the fly
i'm very light-headed right now i am too
we've had a few whiskeys
we've screamed a lot we've talked for
hours
i know i'm very lightheaded all right
yeah you must be because you keep
repeating it all right
this is like comparing apples to
submarines impossible to choose
i said that it was going to be tough i
got to be honest from every episode
we've ever done
ever i don't i truly don't like this
could be a trouncing
i don't know which way this is gonna go
pb j is a classic for sure but grilled
cheese dipped in tomato
soup becomes a dinner where pb j
is not also instead of butter on the
bread you need to lightly coat the
outside with
mayonnaise make a soft and delicious
grilled cheese
this is a monster talking to us right
now
[Laughter]
get the get the f out with your craft
single between white bread
pb j options are damn near unlimited you
can grill that bad boy if for some
reason room temperature is your deal
breaker
yes amy i agree who the hell
i'm gonna revel in this one michael
bease who the hell picks peanut butter
over grilled cheese
i have to imagine it's joe who was
always wrong
hey guess what you lousy bastard
grilled cheese is a hot mess that almost
nobody knows how to make right
good luck enjoying one on a hot day with
grease all over your hands and mouth you
savages
pb and j all day oh yeah all right
here's here's your favorite thing
here's your favorite thing no one ever
says you're the grill to my cheese
people say you're the peanut butter to
my jelly nobody says that either lady i
got news for you
when you think of dynamic duos peanut
butter and jelly are top tier picks
a great snack at breakfast delicious
with milk and coffee it's a go-to
grilled cheese is melted cheese on a bun
if i was poor
that's what i would eat okay let me let
me point out where that tweet falls
apart completely
grilled cheese first of all when you
talk about dynamic duos
okay fine we're not talking about
dynamic duos we're talking about a
sandwich number one
number two grilled cheese has melted
cheese on a bun
what kind of psycho is making grilled
cheese on a bun
number three if that's if i was poor
that's what i eat this
is your fan base here this is who
supports you
this is this is who is he's supporting
peanut butter and jelly this is who is
supporting your argument for pb
j okay this is the pb j audience i want
you to see that
i've seen five pb six pb js in a row
all right one more and then we'll go to
the we'll go to the uh
uh uh win i'm pretty sure they make
songs about peanut butter and jelly
sandwich that's how good they are
they need not say more mic job drop oh
what about ratio that's another
important thing
people like some more peanut butter less
jelly more jelly less peanut butter
it's all up to your personal style and
flair cheese
grilled cheese doesn't have that i'm
seeing a lot of the comments
skewing peanut butter and jelly please
tell me sal as pb j
have disagreed with everything joe has
ever said thus far
[Music]
i'm gonna nominate that i'm gonna
nominate that for
the win i'm gonna
yeah brendan cavallit now where the
hell you say it follow brandon at
brendan which is b-r-e-n-d-a-n-k-o-v
i am i am spent i'm out
oh this is it
[Music]
12 500 votes that is
huge grilled cheese wins 65.9
to 34.1 percent i would have lost
the farm on this bet i didn't know where
it would go but i didn't i didn't think
i didn't think we'd be
we'd lose by that much look at that 12
500 votes and the i mean i have spoken
i'm in shock
team joe derosa has taken the trophy
tonight i still love you buddy
don't be a sore loser i laughed when i
lost
i love you too tough one
don't be a sore loser i'm not don't be
you're being a sore loser right
how old am i because you screamed your
head off and you're wrong so it's just
something
wrong you're wrong i still believe that
how
dare you what do you do no but joe i
yelled at you
because you have some set because you
just
you just you can't just change the rules
i didn't change the rules
all i said was the original
i was going off the original recipe
all right girl cheese is one i still
love you i love you too
oh look i do no no no don't be so i
totally love it don't be sure i
i totally i'm not right but i i can't
believe this like
guys i mean at two brutee
instagram and twitter check it out so uh
as you always say thanks for following
on us yes
leave a review subscribe hit the
reminder bell button
never mind the bell yeah hit the like
button
all these things if you guys are on
community text me 718-260-6619
i have this app i can see your text i
can't answer everybody
but i post things there first and
foremost and things that i don't post
elsewhere
i post there uh so join and everyone
smile i'll get a text and i try to
answer a few
a handful a day uh i don't know man um
that's volcano on socials and
subscribe to the no pressure network and
uh thank you this is
thank you guys we are building up a
community here
that we absolutely love and it's the
most interactive thing we do
and uh we love seeing your comments
share tell somebody if you like it tell
somebody this episode's gonna
upset my mom she she listens to the show
she gets upset at these points rosa
i love you son i love you i'm sorry she
asked after doritos combo she was like
are you guys okay
with each other i'm very concerned i
tell you you were gonna hit each other
at one point
yeah this got worse than that i think i
have to get i have to get a bagel
i gotta get a big holes i know you were
red
i know all right anyway we gotta go bye
taste buzz they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds taste
buds
if you don't want your purse they'll
take your pay stubs
taste buds